♪ ♪
>> Dana: HISTORIC DAY-TO-DAY
AS REPUBLICAN IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS BEGAN, THE G.O.P.
CLAIMING THEIR TESTIMONY RELIES
ON HEARSAY TESTIMONY.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THE
WITCH HUNT, IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT?
I HEAR IT'S A JOKE.
I HAVEN'T WATCHED FOR ONE MINUTE
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN WITH THE
PRESIDENT, AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED.
THIS IS A SHAM.
IT SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED.
I WANT TO FIND OUT WHO IS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND BECAUSE THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER GAVE VERY
INCORRECT INFORMATION INCLUDING
MY CALL WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE WHICH WAS A PERFECT CAL
CALL.
>> Dana: ASIDE FROM THAT,
THERE WAS ALSO A BACK-AND-FORTH
ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN TODAY AND
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WERE
CONCERNS ABOUT HIS POSSIBLE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
WATCH THIS.
>> I RAISE MY CONCERN THAT
HUNTER BIDEN STATUS AS A BOARD
MEMBER WOULD CREATE THE
PERCEPTION OF A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
LET ME BE CLEAR, HOWEVER, THERE
WAS NO EVERYBODY AND HE WAS
OFFICIAL TO SHIELD BURISMA FROM
SCRUTINY.
>> DO YOU KNOW IF HUNTER BIDEN
OFFICE ANYTHING OTHER THAN HIS
DAD IS A FORMER VICE PRESIDENT?
>> I DON'T.
I HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF HUNTER
BIDEN.
>> YOU DEGREE IT RAISES
QUESTIONS, RIGHT
>> YOU AGREE IT RAISES
QUESTIONS?
HE WAS GETTING PAID $50,000 A
MONTH TO SIT ON THE BOARD?
>> Dana: THIS EXCHANGE, JESSE,
GETS TO THE CENTER OF HUNTER
BIDEN BEING ONE OF THE WITNESSES
CALLED, DON'T KNOW IF IT WILL
GET GRANTED.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT IT WAS A
RISK WITH THE BOW TIE.
BUT I THINK IN THE END, IT
WORKED FOR HIM.
>> BREAKING NEWS!
>> IT CAN HELP WITH THE
REPUBLICAN POINT OF VIEW.
HE TESTIFIED UNDER OATH THAT
BURISMA WAS CORRUPT TO THE CORE
AND WANTED IT INVESTIGATED.
HE SAID THE OWNER OF BURISMA
STOLE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
UKRAINE.
ALL OF THE ENERGY LICENSES PAID
OFF THE PROSECUTOR AND FLED THE
COUNTRY.
HE SAID THAT HE RAISED CONCERNS
TO THE BIDEN TEAM ABOUT HUNTER
JOINING BURISMA.
AND HE SAID, THE DEMOCRATS' STAR
WITNESS, THERE WAS NOTHING WRONG
WITH PRESIDENT FROM BRINGING UP
BURISMA WITH THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT.
THAT WAS TOTALLY NORMAL AND
MENTION THE TREATY THAT I
MENTION ALL THE TIME ON THIS
SHOW, HE HAD TOTAL LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO MENTION THAT.
IN THE END, WHEN ASKED ABOUT
JOE BIDEN, DO YOU THINK
JOE BIDEN SINCE HE'S RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, SHOULD NOT BE
INVESTIGATED, HE SAID NO ONE IS
ABOVE THE LAW.
I THINK THOSE ARE ALL GREAT
POINTS FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
>> Juan: LET ME HELP YOU.
I'M GLAD TO HELP YOU.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH THE
PRESIDENT, IF HE IS REPRESENTING
THE UNITED STATES, SAYING IT'S
IN THE NATIONAL SECURITY
INTEREST OF THIS COUNTRY TO GO
AFTER CORRUPTION IN THE UKRAINE.
WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT SAY?
JOE BIDEN, BURISMA, NOT BECAUSE
HE IS INTERESTED IN CORRUPTION,
HE'S INTERESTED IN JOE BIDEN.
YOU CAN'T USE THE LEVERAGE OF
U.S. NATIONAL SECURITY -- IT'S
NOT ABOUT MONEY!
THIS IS NOT A BUSINESS DEAL!
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT
REPRESENTING US AND SAYING I'M
GOING TO USE AMERICAN DOLLARS TO
GET DIRT ON MY POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
>> Greg: HE DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> Katie: THE REASON WHY THE
CORRUPTION ELEMENT IS RELEVANT
HERE WITH BURISMA IS BECAUSE
BURISMA IS A CORRUPT COMPANY AND
HUNTER BIDEN WAS BEING PAID BY
THE COMPANY AND LOBBYISTS
SURROUNDING THE COMPANY AND
OTHER COMPANIES IN THE UKRAINE
WERE GOING TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND TRYING TO
LEVERAGE HUNTER BIDEN'S LAST
NAME TO GET SPECIAL FAVORS FOR
THAT'S WHY THERE'S A CORRUPTION
ELEMENT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PRESIDENT MENTIONING BURISMA OR
HAVING QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
ROLES WERE OF EVERYBODY
INVOLVED.
>> Juan: KATIE, CAN YOU CITE
ME ONE CASE WHERE THE PRESIDENT,
OUR PRESIDENT, HAS GONE AFTER
CORRUPTION WHERE IT DIDN'T
INVOLVE GETTING DIRT ON THE
POLITICAL OPPONENT?
>> Katie: GONE AFTER
CORRUPTION IN CENTRAL AMERICAN,
IN MEXICO --
>> Juan: RIGHT, FOR THE WALL.
>> Greg: IN CHINA.
>> Katie: ONE MORE NOTE ON
THAT.
ZELENSKY, THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE, WAS ELECTED TO COMBAT
CORRUPTION.
AFTER THE HEARING, I THOUGHT
WHAT ADAM SCHIFF SAID ABOUT HIM
WAS VERY INTERESTING.
THEY ARE GOING AFTER THE
CHARACTER AND THE CREDIT ABILITY
OF THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE KEEPS SAYING, HE'S
NOT LYING WHEN HE SAID HE WASN'T
PRESSURED BY THE PRESIDENT.
ADAM SCHIFF IS GOING OUT AND THE
CAMERAS AND SAYING THAT HE IS
NEAR, DOES NOT NECESSARILY WHAT
HE'S DOING, THE PEOPLE HAVE SO
MUCH FAITH IN HIM THAT HE CAN DO
THIS, BUT MAYBE HE WAS
PRESSURED.
>> Dana: THE OTHER THING THAT
BILL TAYLOR SAID ABOUT ZELENSKY
WAS THAT HE WAS NEW AND HE WAS
EXCITED ABOUT HIM BECAUSE HE WAS
GOING TO START DOING SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT UNITED STATES HAD
BEEN ASKING FOR.
>> Greg: HE DIDN'T SEEM LIKE
SOMEBODY WHO WAS BEING EXTORTED
OR HAD NO PROBLEMS WITH WHAT WAS
GOING ON FOR THE FACT IS YOU
CANNOT TURN OFF LEVERAGE WHEN
YOU ARE A BOSS.
IT'S IMPLIED WHETHER YOU SAY IT
OR NOT.
DANA, WHEN YOU ASK YOUR
ASSISTANT FOR A SANDWICH, YOU
DON'T SAY, CAN I HAVE A SANDWICH
OR ELSE?
OR ELSE IS IMPLIED.
BECAUSE YOU ARE A MONSTER.
HE GIVES YOU A SANDWICH, IT'S
OVER.
>> Dana: IF YOU'LL GIVE ME
THAT THERE ON GREG GUTFELD...
>> Greg: IT'S MONEY.
THE LEVERAGE IS THERE WHETHER
YOU LIKE IT OR NOT.
THE ONE THING I LIKE ABOUT THIS
ELEMENT OF THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS, THIS INQUIRY, THE MEDIA
IS ALWAYS TRYING TO PLACE IT
INTO TWO PRISMS.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE FOR OR AGAINST.
BUT THE BIDEN THING DESTROYS THE
WHOLE THING BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
SEE THAT COMING.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE FOR THE INQUIRY
EVEN IF IT DESTROYS BIDEN.
>> Juan: DIDN'T A